[Música]
segunda jornada de la convención
demócrata en eeuu para confirmar su
vaivén como candidato del partido a las
elecciones del 3 de noviembre por
primera vez en 200 años el evento se
desarrolla de manera virtual y para hoy
se esperan las intervenciones del ex
presidente bill clinton y la
representante a la cámara alexandría
ocasión
motín en mali el presidente ibrahim
bubacar keita el primer ministro bruce y
62 funcionarios fueron detenidos con
militares en mama con la capital la
unión africana naciones unidas y varias
potencias mundiales rechazaron los
hechos y llamaron al diálogo
y el paris saint german clasificó a la
final de la champions league por primera
vez en su historia y un evento inédito
bajo estrictas medidas sanitarias sin
público y en una sede única
lisboa tenemos informe con nuestra
enviada especial
iniciamos una nueva tarde de información
de américa latina y del mundo aquí en
france 24 bienvenidos mi nombre es
liliana valencia
empezamos en eeuu donde sigue la
convención demócrata en la que se
confirmará joe biden como el candidato a
las elecciones de noviembre el
presidente de donald trump respondió al
discurso de michelle obama ayer y dijo
que si él llegó a la casa blanca fue por
culpa de la gestión del ex presidente
barack obama
andrés meza muchos tienen los detalles
donald trump ataca de nuevo el
mandatario lanzó una serie de tuits
contra la ex primera dama michelle obama
quien durante su discurso en la
convención demócrata dijo que él no era
el presidente correcto para eeuu que
alguien por favor le expliqué michelle
obama que donald trump no estaría aquí
en la hermosa casa blanca si no fuera
por el trabajo realizado por su esposo
barack obama el mandatario incluso ha
roto una histórica tradición preservada
por los candidatos presidenciales en la
que guardan un bajo perfil mientras se
celebra la convención del partido
oponente
por el contrario trama ha iniciado
viajes de campaña por estados clave de
cara a los comicios por otro lado el
voto por correo sigue siendo motivo de
discordia el director general del
servicio
la plazo hasta después de las elecciones
las medidas que había planteado para
reducir los costos de esta oficina que
incluye el recorte de horas extras de
los trabajadores así como restricción en
el transporte los legisladores
demócratas votarán el sábado una ley
para proteger el servicio postal de lo
que llaman es una campaña del presidente
de donald trump para sabotear el voto
por correo ya que ha insistido sin
pruebas en que ayudará a promover el
fraude electoral
previamente hablamos con esta
corresponsal en washington diana
castañeda quien nos adelantó un poco de
lo que se vivirá esta noche en la
convención demócrata en su segunda
jornada
hola qué tal en esta segunda jornada de
la convención demócrata una convención
virtual la esposa del candidato
demócrata joe bytes gb será la encargada
de dar el discurso central ella va a
hablar sobre la trayectoria profesional
de bairén y también su rol como hombre
de familia igualmente durante estas
jornadas esperan testimonios a través de
vídeos de muchos votantes que se han
visto afectados durante la pandemia y
también que han tenido que sufrir según
lo dicen los demócratas la falta de
liderazgo del presidente de donald trump
y ese será el tema central de esta noche
el liderazgo hablarán también dos
importantes ex presidentes demócratas
carter y bill clinton y se espera la
intervención de el líder del senado
chuck schumer al igual que al ex andrea
cortez quien tiene una gran cantidad de
seguidores jóvenes
y espero esta noche nuestro segundo
especial informativo sobre la convención
demócrata en eeuu a partir de las 8 de
la noche hora de bogotá quito y lima
escucharemos y analizaremos los
discursos que tendrán lugar hasta el
jueves 20 de agosto aquí entre las 24
cambiamos de información porque el
consejo de seguridad de la onu se
reunirá de emergencia el miércoles para
discutir la situación es mala y es que
el presidente ibrahim bubacar keita y el
primer ministro fueron detenidos este
martes por soldados amotinados en lo que
se presume es un golpe de estado el
hecho llega tras meses de protestas
antigubernamentales en contra del
mandatario
un posible golpe de estado en mali
despertó el rechazo de líderes y
organizaciones internacionales pero en
bamako la reacción es diferente
una multitud inundó las calles para
celebrar y agradecer a los soldados de
todo mal y ha sido liberado por una
fuerza republicana al pueblo maliense lo
apoya estamos realmente muy muy felices
no hay educación no hay salud no hay
seguridad todo se le ha dicho al hombre
pero no quiere escuchar a su pueblo la
detención del presidente ibrahim bubacar
keita y el primer ministro bug dice se
produjo después de semanas de protestas
para exigir su dimisión pues lo acusan
de corrupción e incapacidad de
restablecer la seguridad en el país
keita fue reelecto en 2018 pero la
oposición denunció irregularidades desde
entonces malí se encuentra en una
profunda crisis política el movimiento
opositor 5 de junio canalizó la ira
ciudadana por una economía devastada la
corrupción política y un brutal
conflicto yihadista
hemos dicho que no nos negamos a
con el señor que está sino que nos
reuniremos con él para discutir sólo las
condiciones de su partida en condición
de la coalición dijo que la detención de
keita no era un golpe militar sino una
insurrección popular en 2012 un motín ya
había conducido a un golpe militar
derribando al entonces presidente amadou
tumani turé y acelerando la caída del
norte de mali a los militantes y
cadistas
en colombia el expresidente álvaro uribe
vélez renunció a su silla en el senado
el ex mandatario se encuentra detenido
en detención domiciliaria por orden de
la corte suprema de justicia por
presunto fraude procesal y también por
soborno a testigos
decenas de indígenas en el estado
brasileño de pará bloquearon una de las
principales carreteras que atraviesan la
selva amazónica para protestar contra el
gobierno de jair bolsonaro estos pueblos
originarios denuncian el completo
abandono de las autoridades para
combatir el cobo y 19 y acusan al
presidente de promocionar la destrucción
de sus territorios con el aumento de la
deforestación veamos este informe de
álvaro cordero
una huelga para denunciar el abandono
del gobierno los pueblos indígenas del
estado brasileño de pará bloquearon una
de las principales carreteras del
amazonas' provocando retenciones
kilométricas es su protesta contra la
gestión de jair bolsonaro de la crisis
del comit 19 estos pueblos se sienten
abandonados y consideran que varias
personas han fallecido por culpa de la
falta de ayuda y médicos
desafortunadamente hemos perdido a
personas mayores que eran históricas
para nosotros
eran como museos vivos electric tenían
todas nuestras historias que
lamentablemente ahora hemos perdido
a la crisis sanitaria se suma la
ambiental en la amazonas los incendios
han aumentado un 28% desde julio de 2019
algo que bolsonaro desmiente a pesar de
que los datos oficiales corroboraron
esta información esto supone que los
hogares de la tribu kayapó están en
peligro al igual que sus medios de vida
y supervivencia como pueblo esta
manifestación también exige la
protección de la selva tropical desde
aquí se puede ver el humo causado por la
deforestación cada día aumenta y aumenta
desde la llegada al poder bolsonaro ha
apostado por la apertura de la cuenca
del amazonas a la minería y la
agricultura uno de los factores clave
por lo que sus rivales señalan que se
está aumentando la destrucción de esta
región que ocupa el 40% de sudamérica
por primera vez en la historia de la
champions league el equipo paris saint
germain clasificó a la final de una
exitosa campaña durante este torneo el
equipo galo venció al racing de alemania
con tres tantos marcados por martillo
ángel di maria y juan bernat ahora
esperan al ganador del partido este
miércoles entre bayern múnich y el
olympique de lyon la pila se fuera el
próximo domingo en lisboa portugal y
allí se encuentra nuestra enviada
especial natalia ruiz que nos envió
previamente como transcurre la última de
las últimas jornadas de la liga de
campeones en un contexto inédito que es
el de la pandemia
la reanudación de la liga de campeones
debía traer esperanza y lo ha hecho no
solamente a los hinchas del fútbol sino
también a la gente en general porque era
como que la vida volviera a retomar su
curso después de meses de confinamiento
por causa del coronavirus en el mundo
entero lisboa se convirtió en la sede de
la fase final de la liga de campeones-
acogiendo a los 8 mejores equipos que
quedan todavía que quedaban todavía en
competición
lisboa ganó este premio y esto le
debería significar el regreso en masa de
los turistas en parte portugal ganó
llegamos este privilegio por el buen
manejo que ha tenido de la epidemia de
coronavirus a aquí en europa y sin
embargo no se vive un ambiente tan
festivo como debería cuando se trata
sobre todo de la liga de campeones
porque no se ven multitudes de hinchas
en las calles en parte porque los
partidos se disputan a puerta cerrada
sin público sin embargo si nos hemos
cruzado con varios hinchas sobre todo
del parís and drama y del anti que
lionel los dos clubes franceses como
ustedes ven a mis espaldas ellos
baires aquí en el centro de lisboa para
ver los partidos de sus equipos en todo
caso se espera que esta liga de
campeones traiga unas ganancias a la
capital de portugal de unos 50 millones
de euros
así finalizamos en france 24 49 como
siempre al 24 puntos con los vemos más
adelante
[Música]